good afternoon everyone
my name is neil blaney and i'm the head
of place and commercial services at
timbridge district council
it's my pleasure to welcome you all
today and thank you for joining us at
our garden community webinar
i believe we have a mix of attendees
today some of you will know about the
newton albert and king staten garden
community program
i may have attended the previous
workshop and for others this will be
your first involvement
i'll very briefly introduce the program
before handing over to our award-winning
partners um designer david hawes
and architect james barnfield who'll
provide an update on the program
the garden community program is a
partnership between public sector
partners community organizations and
technical experts
some of which are listed on the slide on
your screen
back in 2019 newton albert and king
statement was selected by government to
become a designated
garden community to help revitalize the
area and to shape significant
developments and facilities for local
communities
there are approximately 50 garden cities
towns villages and communities across
the uk
and each one is unique there's no single
guideline as to what a garden community
should look like or feel like
the program is about responding to local
requirements preserving what's great
about an area such as culture
heritage and surroundings while
achieving health economic and
environmental goals identified
through engagement with local
communities it's about creating thriving
environments for everyone including
existing communities where people choose
to live
work and play for generations to come
some of the benefits to the local
community might include job
opportunities
communities connected by green space
public realm areas and biodiversity
community facilities improved transport
links and better provision for active
travel
some of you might be wondering how this
fits in with the local plan
the local plan adopted in 2014 set up
policies to shape new development
identify where future communities may go
and what we want them to be like
the garden community program sets out
how we plan to get there in a
sustainable way
but also covers all of our existing
communities and how they can adapt to
become more sustainable locations
while this work is going on at the same
time as a consultation on an update of
the local plan
the series of workshops we are running
for the garden communities are not a
formal part of that consultation
however this work will ultimately help
to shape the updated local plan policies
this program and the intention of the
workshops is to look at how we
positively enable and deliver change
as our communities grow and adapt to
challenges such as climate change
to make the towns more sustainable and
to leave a positive legacy for future
generations
it will also contribute significantly to
the area's recovery from covert 19.
your input into this work allows you to
be a very positive part of that process
the first stage of this program is to
imagine what could be and to develop a
vision and goals for newton ableton king
state and garden community
an integral part of this process which
is being led by david and james
is to understand and incorporate the
views hopes and aspirations of the local
community
technical experts and public sector
partners
we will achieve this through a series of
workshops which david and james will now
discuss
so over to you david and james thank you
neil
i'm james barnfield from hilton bonfield
architects in exeter
and together with david hawes a talented
local urban designer
we've been helping team bridge district
council identify how
all the neighborhoods in the news
network and garden and kingston region
can benefit from the opportunities
presented by the garden community
program
today we're going to describe to you the
work that we've undertaken so far
and describe how you'll be able to help
us through a series of workshops
that have been designed to learn from
and ultimately
to serve the various neighborhoods that
define
your garden community region
if we weren't in these pandemic times
we'd likely be hosting
one collective event for everyone to get
together
and discuss their community and
neighborhood
so the purpose of this webinar is really
to compensate for that and provide an
introduction or warm up to the
forthcoming workshops
that will take place for each specific
neighborhood
in these workshops we'll be inviting you
to identify and highlight
the attributes and the opportunities
that exist
in your respective local communities so
our introduction today
is to give some context to these events
and explain how
everyone can get the most from this
involvement
i'm just going to share my screen
by means of a quick bit of background
today we've been examining the town and
region in some detail
from the region's landscape and its
origins
to the recent history and work that's
taking place today
and so we've been through this course of
steps
from research and analysis through a
stakeholder workshop and
envisioning some themes which we'll talk
about surely shortly building up towards
the
neighborhood workshops um
so our research analysis has involved a
pretty thorough technical review of
documents like flood risk reports
transport strategies and elements of the
teenbridge local plan to name
just a few but also broader references
such as
national design guidance and sustainable
development goals which
are all quite technical and we're not
going to dwell on too much now
but it's important that we highlight
that we're using this intelligence to
learn how best to frame the future
of your communities and provide you the
public your council members and officers
with the tools to design and deliver
the best possible places to live work
and play
for everyone and for newton abbott and
kingston to be the best it can be
we all have a role to play in
contributing to but also
benefiting from a future where we'll
have to respond to challenges like
climate breakdown but it can all feel
quite
academic or inaccessible at times
and what impact can we have or
contribute to if we can't
see understand or be this change on the
ground
importantly how do you as residents have
a sense of ownership and pride
in this change so these workshops will
be opportunities to
imagine your neighborhood's future
unshackled by technicalities and
bureaucracy
the work we've already done um
sorry this work has already identified
opportunities for the future of newton
albert and king stanton
in fact ahead of the forthcoming
workshop we've applied this focus on
future goals to a preparatory workshop
that we conducted a couple of months ago
where we invited a range of
representatives and stakeholders to
identify their aspirations for the
garden community region
to imagine a shared aspiration that
doesn't have boundaries
with ideas such as renewing connections
with rivers and canals or creating
better bus services
between communities planting trees using
more local resources in building
whatever it may be we collated a long
list of aspirations to go with a
group of stakeholders and
this became quite a kind of long list of
ideas and
goals and dreams which we subsequently
refined and synthesized
into some short lists and key
overarching things so
these themes are locally specific that
can be applied to a broad range of
decision making in the future that are
specific to newton abbott and kingston
and will later serve as a starting point
for identifying
the ingredients to make the best of your
town and your community
our intentions therefore are for these
workshops to be your opportunity
to identify or influence the qualities
and the visible physical outcomes that
are specific to your neighborhood
so our conversation with you today is to
introduce these themes to you
next week's workshops will build on this
further so we can learn
from you how these themes might be
applied or profiled
in your neighborhood so if i just pass
you over to david now
to share the genesis of these themes for
you
we'll take it from there thanks james
um i'm david hawes urban designer
um and um pleased to be working with
team bridge and
james on on preparing this vision for
the garden community for newton abbott
and king stanton
um as as james said we've um we've
gathered all the research and analysis
uh described to inform a series of
snapshots
of the character of newton abbott and
king stanton
and i'm just going to bring these these
plans up to
take you through how these these are
formulated
is not just a timeline um but it's
uh characterization and observation of
important elements of identity and the
function
of newton abbott and king stanton um
the first of these describes the
relationship
the place has with the landscape um it's
a
shape of of settlement has been formed
by geology
uh topography uh the rivers
and the coast and countryside are still
all elements which are very obvious
today for those living in and around
newton
and king stanton the settlements
in the area had their origins on high
ground and within that landscape
and then they grew moving into the
spaces between
uh that high ground and the modern day
town is a result of
the coming together of those historic
places to trade
and to socialize new now
and kingston having become established
have enjoyed
periods of prosperity where the pride in
the place has grown
from the jobs and the lifestyles that
people have which
themselves are connected to the
landscape and
the towns and villages uniqueness and
the resources that lie around the area
with a growing population and a greater
out-migration
from the area the sense of community
has become threatened and in more recent
times local facilities and services
have diminished and yet the demand for
these
and the need among communities is
is ever present particularly as we think
about in response to the pandemic
so from these snapshots of character of
identity and function
we've developed a series of themes which
we've called
themes for future change and
in each of your individual workshops
beginning next week
we'd like you to reflect on these themes
and um ask you to consider their
relevance in your area
so i've now got a series of short films
and animations
which um will introduce each of these
themes for change and the first of these
is called landscape for
the newton opportunity and kingston area
is defined by its landscape
positioned between dartmoor countryside
and coast
the surroundings are visible and
contribute to its identity
from dartmoor three rivers flow through
the town
the lemon the bobby and the team
these have brought life to the landscape
over centuries
and connect the garden community to both
coast
and countryside
working with our surrounding environment
will contribute to improved health and
well-being
the corridors from the river source to
the sea have a significant role to play
providing sustainable travel opportunity
creating green travel routes and open
space
along the river paths and through towns
and villages
also provides opportunities to manage
flood risk in a natural way
and in doing so enables nature recovery
and intensifies biodiversity
new sustainable food and energy supply
chain infrastructure
can encourage trade and collaboration
between communities
within and outside the area
strengthening relationships
between the neighboring coast and
countryside
the garden community can be enhanced by
greening the built environment
creating a uniquely and ecologically
rich townscape
a wild town where new opportunities for
habitat creation
landscape sustainability and
biodiversification
can be explored like never before
connecting people with their communities
and with nature by enhancing a
relationship with the landscape
sustainable healthy travel routes will
provide much-needed connections
to place and shared spaces creating
opportunities for communities to
flourish
these will support local innovation
resourcefulness
and diversification and can enhance what
makes communities unique
as well as what joins them together
and the second theme for change is
called thriving together
historically many villages in the garden
community area
originated on higher ground and
overlooked the valleys and estuary
villages expanded and descended over
time
to surround the valleys of the rivers
resulting in market trade between the
villages
it was this connection where communities
found
collective places to meet and access
shared facilities
that would give rise to its diversity
and success
the recent history of low density
single-use developments and large
buildings in the low-lying landscape
have contributed to diluting the links
between places
the garden community project presents
the opportunity
to reconnect new and historic
communities
whilst also connecting with the
landscape
it is an opportunity to reveal the
region's existing assets
and under utilize spaces that following
in the footsteps of the town's origins
can serve as a meeting ground and a
framework
for social economic and environmental
activity to flourish
intuitive wayfinding informed by the
function of a place
and its landscape will support an active
and integrated travel network
the opening up of these meeting places
at accessible locations
throughout the region can create a rich
mix
of uses and activities
the third theme for future change we've
called
growing local
the garden community area is built upon
a strong legacy of enterprise and
entrepreneurial spirit
culminating in a thriving market town
over time there has been a shift away
from the home grown expertise
local resources and innovation which
newton iowa and king state and was built
upon
while still present as the economy and
communities of new canada develop
there has been a shift from utilizing
the town's own resources and trades
to being part of a wider network of
modern industry
looking to the future there is an
opportunity to reawaken an
entrepreneurial spirit
and harness physical resources and human
ingenuity
in order to help the town's economy
thrive create jobs
and nurture retain and attract young
talent to support the wealth of industry
the area provides
there is an opportunity to define a 21st
century market town
during community innovation the unique
setting and rich resources
and building an intrinsic link between
education training and local industries
locally sourced food fuel and resources
can create a modern agricultural and
manufacturing community
reconnecting people with their local
history of their landscape and town or
village
creating spaces in which people and
businesses of all sorts can come
together to collaborate
and innovate can give rise to a new
generation of ideas and enterprise
the garden community project seeks to
enhance the regional interconnectivity
and reciprocal interdependency of the
already established resourceful
industries that exist in the area
as well as nurturing new and innovative
ones
in doing so a sense of pride can be
reclaimed in local innovation and
homegrown talent
and the fourth theme for future change
is
a community of communities
within the garden community are many
distinctive communities
residential social commercial and
virtual
now more than ever the distinctiveness
of these individual communities
is threatened by the need to travel
trade
and join in various ways with others
locally
nationally and globally
as well as having their own unique
identity
these communities are interdependent
the garden community project offers the
opportunity to build on existing
connections
to integrate new communities physically
socially and virtually
by the overlapping activities
demographics communities and nature
a vibrant diversity of lifestyles can be
celebrated
the garden community project can secure
the distinctiveness
function and sustainability of each
individual community across the area by
identifying their
unique contribution to the wider economy
in society
okay so that was a a brief run through
by um film and animation of the themes
that uh we have prepared to
underpin the vision for the garden
community but
um you know the constituent parts of
this whole area are your
neighborhoods and as james described
initially in positioning the workshops
describing the purpose of the workshops
which start next week
um understanding how these vision themes
apply
to your neighborhood and the priority of
design
that you that you have in your area is
is really key to under
to this process so the purpose of the
workshop starting next week
is for you to reflect on each of these
themes
and will will help you through that
exercise and
the design of the events to think about
whether
one or other of these is a is a greater
priority
um and what relevance they have to your
neighborhood
and how they can bring about the change
that you would like to see in your
neighborhood
this webinar and information on these
drivers
uh on on these themes for change
that that drive the vision uh is going
to remain available on
teamview's website and and we'd
encourage you to
reflect on these before you attend your
workshop next week for your given
neighborhood
so just like to thank you for
participating today and listening in and
and we look forward to seeing you in the
workshops from
next week